[Music]
what was dismissed as nerd stuff 20
years ago is now the inspiration for the
most successful films of all time
we're talking about superhero movies be
the marvel cinematic universe or the dc
extended universe the two comic giants
have been dominating the big screen for
years
and who doesn't feel like slipping into
the role of their favorite hero for just
a few hours
yet whether this is always so much fun
is a different story because according
to many actors
the costumes are not always as great as
we imagined them to be
sometimes costumes are too heavy too
tight or
just very inconvenient in some parts
since we don't want to deprive you of
any detail
today we give you examples of actors who
hated their superhero costumes
who better to start a less than the
father of success when you think of the
mcu
namely robert downey jr don't worry
we're not gonna give you sleepless
nights and tell you he hated his role or
anything like that
the fact is however that when iron man
was filmed in the mid-2000s
cgi was unfortunately not yet up to
today's standards
while almost the entire costume was
created on the computer in the last
avengers parts
he unfortunately still had to get into
the real suit of armor in the first part
this was not only heavy and inflexible
but also very tight
downey jr not only told stories about
several claustrophobic episodes
but also stated that he almost died
during the shooting in the desert
we obviously hoped that this was just an
exaggeration on his part
fortunately technology has advanced
considerably in the meantime and we have
been able to admire him in many
different suits
it's hard to imagine what would have
happened if he had left the franchise
for a while
why because he's iron man
as one of the movies not very popular
among fans x-men apocalypse joined the
ranks of the franchise
even though the idea behind the film was
certainly not bad it couldn't keep up
with the success of its predecessors
as pity as you could see some promising
mutants in the movie
one of them was betsy braddock also
called psylocke
we'd already known the character from
the 2006 film x-men the last 10 in which
the mutant was still played by a mailing
melon song
ten years later someone knew was allowed
to slip into the role namely the
beautiful
olivia munn she was very happy about her
all but
not so happy about her costume according
to the motto's sex cells the costume
makers wanted to show a lot of skin and
let the scars fabric fit
very tightly as a result the costume
apparently tore very often during action
scenes
according to hollywood insiders man had
to grease herself with vaseline over and
over again in order to fit
well into the costume none of it helped
because a costume also flopped with the
critics which is actually a shame when
you look at the original costume used in
the comics
when you think of ron paul man you think
of movies like pacific rim fantastic
beasts or
the series sons of anarchy many do not
associate him with the anti-hero hellboy
from the 2004 movie of the same name
though which is probably caused by the
fact that the costume actually covers
his entire
body in this case the only thing left
over by the makeup artist were his
eyelids
pearlman himself said in the interview
that he actually quickly grew sick of
the costume
he was getting tired of the amount of
effort that went to getting him into the
costume
every day however he did fall in love
with his character so much that he
didn't want to step down from the role
we were still very happy about that
today as the early hellboy films from
2004 and 2008
are still very much worth watching
make sure you can piss in that suit that
was probably the most important piece of
advice
dark knight actor christian bale gave
his successor ben affleck
but this video is not about the classic
black suit in which our dark
knight chases the bad guys through
gotham today is about the armor which he
developed specifically for the fight
against superman
not only does it look very powerful but
of course it is also very powerful
unfortunately it was so heavy and bulky
that had to be taken off during the
fight scenes and cgi had to be used
instead
a small shortcoming that you can forgive
the makers for sure
since the superhero movie without fights
would certainly have been quite boring
makarobi is one of the most popular
actresses of recent years
she made her breakthrough in 2013 and
the wolf of wall street
today however people tend to associate
her with a crazy anti-heroine harley
quinn from the dc universe
she first appeared in suicide squad in
2016 and she was so popular that she
even got her own movie last year with
birds of prey
according to her own statement however
she had to get used to her costume first
as unlike that of her teammates and
suicide squad it was more sexy rather
than a helpful
or dangerous while the others all wore
black combat suits
roby had to squeeze into tied hot pants
and drenched white shirts
this made her a real eye catcher in the
movie and suicide squad insiders even
say that she got so used to it by the
end
that she once left her wet costume on
during lunch break to comfortable eat a
burger with the others
probably one of the most complex
costumes in the superhero franchise was
given to paul batonis vision in the mcu
movies
some of you might have thought that this
costume and look was created on a
computer but that's wrong
bethany spent hours every morning before
filming began getting put on makeup and
getting dressed in an air permeable suit
where other acting colleagues would have
surely gone crazy paul fought his way
through
when asked how he managed it he said in
an interview that he mainly spent a lot
of time
reading and practicing meditation as
soon as unpleasant feelings or even
slight claustrophobia appeared
kudos to him and of course we are all
excited to see him in the new wonder
vision marvel series which is currently
streaming on disney plus
please don't make the super suit green
or animated
that's what ryan reynolds said in
deadpool and if you're wondering what
was meant by that we can assure you that
you didn't miss anything
we still have to clarify the whole thing
what was probably insinuate was the
first completely computer animated
superhero suit from green lantern
what was hoped to be a revolution at the
time was torn apart by fans and critics
alike and even the actors didn't have
many good words to say about the look of
the suits
deadpool director tim miller for example
specially included a side swipe or two
against green lantern in the film to
this day reynolds vows never to step
into the role of green lantern again
even though the rumors about a new film
won't die down not every superhero has
to wear elaborate makeup or heavy armor
to feel uncomfortable
sometimes it's enough to just put
someone into a far too tight full
bodysuit to make them
feel uncomfortable this is the case with
tom holland in the role of spiderman for
example
the suit was very tight so it was
difficult for the actor to play the
complex and very acrobatic action scenes
as if that wasn't enough the costume was
almost airtight causing him to sweat a
lot under the rubber suit just after a
few minutes
but holland was not the first spider
actor to complain about this costume
his predecessor andrew garfield had
already mentioned the same problems
however he went even further so
apparently the costume designers didn't
think about the fact that an actor also
has to go to the bathroom once in a
while
thus he had to take off almost the
entire costume every time he had to go
for a pee
quite an exhausting process we think
we saved the actress who probably hid it
the hardest with their costume and its
consequences for the end
we are talking about the part-time
heroin and villain mystique from
x-men played by jennifer lawrence
whoever thought that her costume was
created by cgi is barking up the wrong
tree
the makers want the costume to look
exactly like that of rebecca romine from
the first x-men parts
so a total of seven makeup artists put
makeup on lawrence for hours
on end every day of shooting and covered
her with silicon scales
this was to create a kind of snakeskin
effect after that she was sprayed with
many different layers of paint to make
it look even more real
the result looked very real indeed but
gave lauren's bad past rashes and
allergic reactions
all over her skin it wasn't until she
told management that she was considering
dropping out due to the impact on her
body that her costume was adjusted
less silicone and more color was used in
addition to making the suit slimmer
well with such physical consequences
everyone would have understood if she
had called it quits
in the end all we can say is thank
goodness they all held on because
without them
the movie certainly wouldn't have become
what they are today
if you enjoyed the video feel free to
leave us a thumbs up if we forgot anyone
who should have been included on this
list please let us know in the comments
down below
see you next time
[Music]